uh 16 percent of our graduates work in
the um in the high-tech industry and our
goal is in the next three years to bring
it to 30 so it doesn't mean
that those who will not go will not be a
success story as long as we help them
maximize their dreams and working
whatever they want we still
have the responsibility and the ability
to bring more teenagers
into the high-tech industry
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this episode is with a very very
special woman if at behold the ceo of
unistream an organization that provides
entrepreneurship education and
innovating thinking for youth in
israel's geographic and social periphery
in order to reduce socioeconomic
disparity and ensure equal opportunity
for all
ifa joined unistream after serving as
the head of business development and
innovation for birthright israel her
career started at publicis worldwide
then moving to the marketing team at
lowe's cineplex she discovered the world
of philanthropies through friends of the
idf where she served as vp marketing ifa
joined birthright as the executive
director of birthright excel the
lifelong leadership and business
fellowship
she is a member of the maus leadership
fellowship and the schusterman
fellowship she lives in israel with her
husband and three children
[Music]
i want to start with a big thank you
because a lot of people and you know not
not too many people are in tech in the
world right and it's a real privilege to
be in the in the industry the ecosystem
we are in you are using
your
ability time and and and expertise to
help others get into the field and to
open opportunities
break barriers break circles and and
it's really really amazing because
really you can be working at any company
at any executive role and you choose to
to run the amazing unistream
organization which really is is making a
tremendous tremendous impact on the
israeli ecosystem and is a
model that i think many many other
countries should uh should proceed with
so
in fact thank you very much for being
here and
tell me just a little bit about yourself
as a person absolutely so um
as a person i uh you know we just moved
back a few months ago we were uh living
in new york for many years and now we're
in tel aviv i have
amazing three kids and my husband
i i would say that unistream is um is an
amazing a unique experience to be uh you
know to lead such an organization
um when i started my career i really
thought that um i'll be working in
marketing that's what i did i worked in
public seats for many years and
then i moved to new york thinking that
i'm going to work in entertainment
marketing um working for
low cineplex and hbo was a dream
and somehow when they merged with
another company with amc someone offered
me to replace her in a
in front of the idf and i was like sure
three months i will replace her
uh apply for hbo and suddenly i was
there i
i stayed there for nine years
and i i learned throughout the years uh
through fadf and then uh moving to
birthright leading bertrand excel uh
which
you know very well
the leadership and business fellowship
of birthright
that uh my passion and my unique value
proposition i would say is this
i would say tin line or this triangle
between the business world social impact
and entrepreneurship slash innovation
that's what i did in the last few years
um
with this maybe leadership and education
line that connects these three uh
elements
um so
absolutely i think that unistrum is a
great place
for that and really to work and support
the younger generation of israel um when
they move up their careers
fantastic so we're going to unravel this
triangle and understand a little bit you
know the the
the economic system of the strangle
right it all comes down to economics at
the end and and while this organization
you know is a non-profit and it's an
amazing organization with high impact it
also it's a scalable model and you're
it's built as a company that that you
know works very similarly to a tech
company and so sure first share with me
a little bit about unit stream as an
organization you know a little bit about
the story of unistream and then i'd love
to dive deeper into the strategy of what
it's like running this organization and
how you're thinking through maximizing
and optimizing on the impact so i'll
start with you know
what you know better than
me like you know startup nation israel
it's an amazing startup nation but it's
not yet an inclusive start-up nation
uh there's still 30 percent of israel's
children live under the poverty line
about 20 percent
do not have computers at home 27 percent
do not have internet
we work with
teenagers from israel geographic and
social periphery
and we teach them and we work with them
on
building startups with the idea that
you know entrepreneurship is is a model
that can be a life-changing experience
by the skills that it gives you the
methodologies uh but more than that it's
really the basic the idea that there are
no glossy links that um even the
greatest uh entrepreneur in the world
got a few rejections before someone
believed in him it doesn't matter where
he was born and it's really about
believing in yourself feeling
comfortable within the non-comfortable
zone and giving an equal opportunity for
success
for every teenager that lives in the
country
right and so with with this
huge and grand vision
unistream is born and what what does the
actual program consist of right
stream so uh we work with about 3 500 um
teenagers from everywhere in israel from
kirachmann no big
we work with all sectors which is really
a privilege especially in crazy weeks
like this week
we have
we have 22 entrepreneurship centers
where we work with uh
teenagers mostly 9th grade to 11th grade
really on the you know startup creation
everything from you know team
information ideation validation
they get to work very closely to uh the
business sector and i would say that
that's one of the greatest uh values um
the the linear line between every child
every teenager
and a business mentor and companies uh
is amazing it's a great inspiration it's
a great network and it also gives them
um you know the confidence and
methodologies for uh for life
um so we have 22 centers and we also
have an amazing collaboration for a one
year program with uh israel's innovation
authority and education uh office the
minister of education
um which allows us to give this amazing
program
to uh over 90 municipalities
in israel working with a younger
audience usually
seventh and eighth grade uh we have uh
they they have competitions during
during the year uh they work on business
models they they learn how to fundraise
and then every year we have an annual
event with about
2500 people
uh all you know people from tri-sector
from the government from the business
sector coming to see them
it's uh the most
exciting expo of ideas that you can
imagine
it's a it's incredible and it's
inspiring
if we're looking at
this experience from the lens of a
participant you know you know and you
know when we build products
we created the persona and we try to
envision their customer their consumer
journey customer journey
what what is it like for them walk me
through sort of the exp personal
experience that an average participant
may experience throughout a year at
university i love this question
also because we we talk a lot about the
uh you know the the quantitative and how
many but when you when you come to the
quality when you listen to the
individual stories that's when you
really
cry and you understand what an amazing
privilege you have to work with is
brilliant brilliant teenagers um
so
we we accept every every teenager that
has the motivation to come and work with
a team
um they will come and you know they will
start by thinking locally about the
community
and
like the national and the global
challenges that are around them so it's
a lot about problem solving how do you
define a problem and how can you find a
solution for that uh they will think
about some ideas
then they will meet with some business
people with go no go competition uh
committees uh they will think about the
visit the feasibility of the uh venture
and they will continue from there the
second year they will already um decide
if they want to take the uh the place of
uh the finest person
uh the ceo the product person and then
we will help them um understand more
about the niche that they
that they decided to uh
to dedicate their time for
and that's what they will do they will
then build business models
and continue the uh the committee's
meetings that will give them more
insights of what direction to take um
the third year is already about
marketing and fundraising
and um and they meet together i mean
some of them are
some of them know each other uh some of
them don't we have three uh three
centers of what you call shared society
uh it's arab and jewish teenagers
working together
and
when you speak to them you understand
that first of all the center is much
more than just a center it's a second
home for them they come they have food
there they come to do their homework
sometimes and even those who graduated
continue to come
we work and this is uh an amazing thing
that we can do we continue working with
our graduates um during their
uh you know academic like some go to the
idea we work with them during their um
college universities and we also help
them when they want to integrate
into professional life
incredible and so
you're mentioning a few things here that
i want to make sure that i really
understand first it's this notion of a
second home
and the fact that this is not just a
you know it's not just an
extracurricular activity that you do a
course that you're in because you know
on the paper it may seem that the great
you're doing an entrepreneurship course
there are a lot of them around the world
and you're teaching them the the skills
to become entrepreneurs but but when
you're but but there's a community
aspect here and the second thing that i
think is important here is this
multi-year uh process right this is not
a
five-week accelerator to jumpstart your
startup this is a a life-changing
experience that they commit to and you
mentioned the word motivation so let's
talk about that you know why is
motivation and commitment
an important part of the unit stream
experience and the part in into to help
them really get to where they want it's
a journey and we want
something first of all you want to make
sure that you want that you are
accepting every person even if he's more
on the quiet side or even if he's a
person that has a hard time you know
it's cool and you want him to thrive
during you know this amazing place that
allows him to think and bring him his
own value right so the only thing that
is related is the fact that he's willing
to uh dedicate a time work with a team
and um you know stay there for for a
year for two years for three years um i
think that more and more they see also
the potential i i'm proud to say that
ronitsau who is the founder who uh
started uni stream 20 years ago
he made his first investment in a
startup of one of the uh
unistream graduates yes uh-huh really so
i think that i understand that they are
also going to join an amazing community
uh that will support them and give them
many many um
tools uh even when they finish our
program and finish school so
yeah so the kpi from your perspective
you know
you know you're running this
organization
what's the what's the goal here is the
goal here to create
a variety of amazing startups that will
make israel you know a better startup
nation is that the end goal or is it is
it something more about the participants
as well where where is this actually say
that we are
we're working now on on even better
defining the uh the evaluation and the
research that we do like how do you
check mobility what is real mobility
when it comes to economic mobility
social mobility um and what is what is
our place right
in the place of the high tech right we
we encourage a symbiotic relationship
between uh the business sector the uh
the public sector and us
uh but we also have an amazing uh group
of let's say captivated audience of
amazing teenagers that can be
the next uh entrepreneurs and employees
of the itec industry so right now uh 16
of our graduates work in the um in the
high-tech industry and our goal is in
the next three years to bring it to 30
so it doesn't mean that those who will
not go will not be a success story as
long as we help them
um
maximize their dreams and work in
whatever they want we still
have the responsibility and the ability
to bring more teenagers
into the high-tech industry
right okay so now the talking about the
triangle right the triangle that you're
that where that the unit stream is
trying to piece together
what are what are the different
counterparts in this triangle what do
they care about and then how are you
balancing
making sure that everybody's you know
creating a win-win-win situation it's
about the uh the participants right the
teenagers and
um
everywhere um yeah i think that if i
i'll try to make it very briefly
if 20 years ago only understood the the
place of entrepreneurship as uh
as a enabler i think that in the last
few years it became um
you know an element that uh the
government sees the importance of it
right the
um
uh the education minister of education
wants to bring coding and
entrepreneurship into formal education
uh the business industry the high-tech
industry understand that they have to
support and plan the seat for their next
employees
and we see it as a way to look at the
periphery and understand that there is a
huge untapped market
that can actually
um
you know get the support and get the the
tools
to become part of this uh you know
high-tech nation that we are so the
triangle is basically a win-win
that um that will allow
all sectors to um
to enjoy the uh the fruits
of
seeing the teenagers supporting them
giving them the tools
and uh helping them
get to uh you know to this inclusive
startup nation that i'm talking about
and as you're thinking about scale and
quality at scale and part of the
struggle here and i'm sure not not a
struggle but a challenge for an
organization like this is we're talking
about you know numbers are great but at
the end if we're looking at the
individual stories that's where the
crying happens right and that's where
the and that's where the emotions come
in and you understand the impact there's
not many products that people build
where you can really say this is a
life-changing product for people and and
unistream is a product because if you
think about it that way that's when you
can really scale it and make it a
successful opportunity
that said
how are you thinking through scaling
while maintaining quality what are sort
of the big pillars that go through
is to
look at a few elements that are very
important english is one of them english
is a huge barrier in israel okay so
uh even if you do like amazingly well in
your matriculation exams not enough
spoken english so we take english to the
next level not only by presentations but
really bringing them to speak with uh
teenagers from all over the world just
to practice english and to work on
hackathons together so global the global
expansion
is one
uh that is very important in terms of
the scale
um
we are right now doing a an amazing
process of kind of rethinking uh the
product are we still relevant to our
teenagers you know the young gen z
um
if uh you know if having arduino or a
3d printer in our um centers a few years
ago something exciting right now they're
always like two steps ahead of us so how
do we make sure that we are with the
technology that we bring
with um the extra curriculum that we
bring like english like a little bit of
coding
how do we make sure that we are still
two steps ahead so they have enough
value to say
we want to be there uh i will say that
once they are there
they they become a family they become
like they have their you know
um
uh they're like a uni they're so proud
but to make them come
uh it's really about always being agile
and keep thinking uh are we still two
steps ahead of this crazy
fast forward generation that is uh
learning technology is much faster than
it was before
um
and it's also about finding the right
partners
that will see the potential
uh and will invest
with us as real you know in real
collaborations like um
running uh
like you know
like long ways and not just like
thinking about it today
right is this model something that
you know could work in others in other
situations in other countries for
example i'm in israel you know obviously
we have the peripheries and from kiryat
mona to a lot and and we have the
startup nation that can bring together
these 2500 amazing amazing people for
these final for for the for the big you
know showcasing but if we're looking at
other places around the world is this a
model that could work around different
countries that may not have yeah even a
startup nation
i had a few discussions with argentina
and costa rica and a few places where
like costa rica uh actually a hedge fund
there that said that costa rica is not
producing enough entrepreneurs and
they're trying to find a way to do that
so they brought entrepreneurship into
the formal education but it's too formal
so they're trying now to understand how
the informal system can actually
leverage and bring uh methodologies like
unistreams methodology into their um you
know
agenda and work argentina is the same
uh place south africa
uh so absolutely i would say that you
that the united states is a great place
for collaboration
but
they have enough entrepreneurs there are
other countries that um can leverage on
this combination of supporting
periphery
uh while
also investing in the next generation of
entrepreneurs at the same time
uh so
the united states has it in some places
obviously but it's more countries that
are smaller or different like uh the
ones that i mentioned
both for the episode but for the amazing
work this was so fascinating and
inspiring and enjoyable
best of luck with your stream continue
making a huge huge positive impact it's
really inspiring to to see it from the
side and
and um and thank you also for the
amazing work you know in the previous
organizations you've been a part of
particularly birthright excel that was
it holds a special place in my heart and
we didn't get to talk about them because
unistream is so magnificent but but they
are no less and
thank you for everything stay safe and
stay healthy thank you so much have a
lovely weekend thank you michael
bye